Okay, go ahead.
Even if you feel like he's late, because there's nobody to take a decision for you,
in any case we have to do some procedures.
Okay?
There are some things that relate to you, but there are some things that relate to us as a family,
and relate to this family where we are.
Yes.
And you are very good at helping people, starting things like what you already said before.
I am telling you, hey, you need me.
How can I help you?
No, it's too late.
It requires a lot of energy to do, just to overcome such an atomic bomb that you're struggling.
And then you tell me, hey, send me an email.
Why write it down here?
I am the one who has to be speaking.
You said you have to tell me something important.
I have to tell you a lot of things important, but...
I am the one who has to be shut down.
Okay, go on.
I am trying my best to listen, but you're perseverating on this initial reaction that I had.
So, can you actually tell me what the important thing is?
Yes.
I just want to...
For information, you know this pattern that you have to be in the whole night.
And after one a.m. that I...
That you are supposed that I am sleeping, you are going out and buying all these types of food that I understand to eat.
If you want to eat, I rather prefer that we have this wonderful soup, or even bell, or anything
that you can eat, you can eat.
You can eat food.
Food, so you can eat.
Rather than getting the...
Other words.